[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chapter seven
somewhere inside her coraline could feel
a huge sob welding up
and then she stopped it before it came
out she took a deep breath
and let it go she put out her hands to
touch the space in which she was
imprisoned
it was the size of a broom closet tall
enough to stand in or to sit in
not wide or deep enough to lie down in
one wall was glass and it felt cold to
the touch
she went around the tiny room a second
time running her hands over every
surface that she could reach
feeling for doorknobs or switches or
concealed catches some kind of way out
and found nothing a spider scuttled over
the back of her hand and she choked back
a shriek
but apart from the spider she was alone
in the closet and the pitch dark
and then her hand touched something that
felt for all the world like somebody's
cheek and lips
small and cold and a voice whispered in
her ear hush and shush
say nothing for the belden might be
listening coraline said nothing
she felt a cold hand touch her face
fingers running over it like the gentle
beat of a moth's wings
another voice hesitant and so faint
coraline wondered if she were imagining
it
said art thou art thou alive
yes whispered coraline poor child said
the first voice
who are you whispered coraline names
names names said another voice all far
away and lost
the names are the first things to go
after the breath is gone and the beating
of the heart
we keep our memories longer than our
names i still keep pictures in my mind
of my governess on some may morning
carrying my hoop and stick and the
morning sun behind her and all the
tulips bombing the breeze
but i have forgotten the name of my
governess and of the tulips too
i don't think tulips have names said
coraline they're just tulips
perhaps said the boys sadly but i've
always thought that these tulips must
have had names
they were red and orange and red and red
and orange and yellow
like the embers in the nursery fire of a
winter's evening
i remember them the voice sounded so sad
that coraline put out a hand to the
place where the voice was coming from
and she found a cold hand and she
squeezed in tightly
her eyes were beginning to get used to
the darkness now coraline saw or
imagined
she saw three shapes each as faint and
pale as the moon
in the daytime sky they were the shapes
of children about her own size
cold hand squeezed her hand back thank
you said the voice
are you a girl asked coraline or a boy
there was a pause when i was small i
wore skirts and my hair was long and
curled
it said doubtfully but now that you ask
it does seem to me that one day they
took my skirts and gave me britches and
cut my hair
paint something we give a mind to said
the first of the voices
a boy perhaps then continued the one
whose hand she was holding i believe i
was once a boy
and it glowed a little more brightly in
the darkness of the room behind the
mirror
what happened to you all asked coraline
how did you come here
she left us here said one of the voices
she stole our hearts and she stole our
souls and she took our lives away
and she left us here and she forgot
about us in the dark
you poor thing said coraline how long
have you been here
so very long a time said a voice i time
beyond reckoning said another voice
i walked through the scullery door said
the voice of the one that she thought it
might be a boy and i found myself back
in the parlor
but she was waiting for me she told me
she was my other mama
but i never saw my true mama again
fleece at the very first of the voices
another girl coraline
flee while there's still air in your
lungs and blood in your veins and warmth
in your heart
flee while you still have your mind in
your soul i'm not running away said
coraline
she has my parents i came to get them
back uh but she'll keep you here while
the days turn to dust and the leaves
fall and the years pass one after the
next like the tick tick ticking of a
clock
no said coraline she won't there was
silence
then in the room behind the mirror pair
adventure said a voice in the darkness
if you could win your mama and your papa
back from beldum
you could also win free our souls
has she taken them asked coraline
shocked
i and hidden them that is why we cannot
leave here when we died she kept us and
she fed on us
until now we've got nothing left of
ourselves only state snakeskins and
spider husks
find our secret hearts young mistress
and what will happen to you if i do ask
coraline
the voices said nothing what is she
going to do to me
she said the pale figure is pulsed
faintly
she could imagine that there were
nothing more than after images like the
glow left by a bright light in your eyes
after the lights go out
doth not hurt whispered one faint voice
she will take your life and all you are
and all you cares for and she will leave
you with nothing but mist and fall
she'll take your joy and one day you'll
awake and your heart and your soul will
be gone
a husk you'll be a wisp you'll be and a
thing no more than dream on waking
or a memory of something forgotten
hollow whisper the third voice
hollow hollow hollow hollow you must
please cite a voiced family
i don't think so said coraline i tried
running away and it didn't work
she took she just took my parents can
you tell me how to get out of this room
if we knew then we would tell you poor
things that coraline to herself she sat
down
she took off her sweater and rolled it
up and put it behind her head as a
pillow
she won't keep me in the dark forever so
coraline she brought me here to play
games
games and challenges the cat said i'm
not much of a challenge here in the dark
she tried to get comfortable twisting
and bending herself to fit the cramped
space behind the mirror
her stomach rumbled she ate her last
apple taking the tiniest bites making it
last as long as she could
when she finished she was still hungry
then an idea struck her and she
whispered
when she comes to let me out why don't
you three come with me
we wish that we could they said to her
and they're barely their voices
but she has our hearts in her keeping
now we belong to the dark and to the
empty places
the light would shrivel us and burn oh
said coraline
she closed her eyes which made the
darkness darker and she rested her head
on the rolled-up sweater
and she went to sleep and as she fell
asleep she thought she felt a ghost kiss
her cheek
tenderly and a small voice whisper into
her ear
a voice so faint it was barely there at
all a gentle wispy nothing of a voice
so hushed that coraline could almost
believe she was imagining it
look through the stone it said to her
and then she slept
you